pork chop where did you uh where'd you
pork chop
pork loin where did you uh get hot dogs
at
uh vicious dogs and that's in l.a it's
in north hollywood
and that's that place you want to shut
up about yeah
hot dogs i want sausages i just
i hear and it might be a rumor but i
think i'm right
that they take the udders the lips and
the [ __ ]
because you got to do something with
that they grind that up spice it up
and that's in your hot dog now can you
look up what's in a hot dog
it's these scraps but it makes sense it
doesn't
because none of us really cares do we
all does let me give a [ __ ]
well that's the question i don't know i
like your knives in general you don't no
that's what we were saying when have you
had a good one i can't remember last
night i went on a monster jam man
and it was fantastic you had a hot dog
there yeah yeah there's a bun
it's all about the bun who yeah i like
brats i like a thick brown
brat's good too but i think that's the
same situation daddy no brats or
brats are usually real like pork but it
ain't in it the same situation
like the apple could be the snout of the
pig
remain so remains is pretty general yeah
it's very gentle but it's but it but
it's
probably everything you can get the 100
beef franks
but they but you're still getting
scrotum skin yeah 100 yeah
all the [ __ ] that
do you ever eat you ever eat um tongue
steer tongue it's disgusting oh yeah
they'll cut they'll slice
their tongue up even even google's
pretty general
general have you have you had cow tongue
language i have and it's disgusting
didn't know that
tacos couldn't get enough of these uh
wonderful little balls that were in
lemon and yogurt sauce when i was at a
lebanese restaurant
i ate them and i ate all of them and
they were they were goat balls
wait what is it like nuts they're goat
nuts but i didn't realize it because
they're so delicious because they were
in
lemon and yogurt sauce what's that i'm
thinking they were like like a round
like a meatball
and another thing about me guys i got
another story goose goose
in your mouth yep i ate were they juicy
why ain't a whole bowl of how big were
they
goat balls they're about that big and
they're delicious it was a good bowl of
goat balls
prepared juice no you didn't know until
after the fact didn't know tell me why
why is this hot dog place good
meatball uh because like give him
another one
yeah i just keep throwing it um because
so
the one i get people yeah that's what it
originally was
icon meatball long island iced tea
[Music]
it's not very funny well what do you
mean you're the one who's this guy he's
got yeah he's got food
because he's calling them food who
brought the old guy yeah you
you rock what's it like or the rock well
it's random you're saying like pot roast
why can't i call him mountain he's
italian because we're sticking with the
job
all right he's from long island right
rhode island rhode island hey eggplant
so they had like it's not like a normal
hot dog place like i get this thing
called the goomba dog it's like a
italian sausage like a sweet sausage
with love them chicken cutlet
i'm out mozzarella marinara you said
last night
too much what happened too much chicken
on a hot dog
two cups insane dude you gotta see it
brian
which one do you get defeats the purpose
you gotta you gotta see what it looks
like you ate there two cow oh yeah i
had it like five times oh wow yeah but
then that's good
that's a short king thing oh no
yeah just eat just eat the hot dog and
then the chicken shout out they have mac
and cheese one too which is fire no
too much i don't even [ __ ] with
vegetables like your classic dog
relish little onions mustard don't knock
it till you try that's all i gotta say
it's heavy though you're trying to [ __ ]
your pants or what i didn't
actually and kyle don't take a date
there dude no no i didn't i just went by
myself
there you go that's a solo thing kyle
shows up with a [ __ ]
pocket full of condoms and a chili dog
yeah
[Laughter]
it's just it's a heavy dog they're i'm
telling you they're amazing what's it
called vicious dogs
no i don't see the point i mean it's
just a giant hot dog with nothing on it
like
it's american dude it's just a hot dog
with ketchup and mustard for god's sakes
this new age [ __ ] yeah that's a lot
but have you have you had one the the
hot dogs from like the mexican vendors
around
oh yeah yeah and stuff with the it's
wrapped in bacon yeah [ __ ] those are
phenomenal
that's really good this is called the
what
buffalo you know what i had the other
day i had a on the way back from the
podcast you saw my daughter
have myself a nice you guys going to
make fun of me at taco bell
had a taco bell you had taco bell i
never have had that and i had a burrito
and it was
[ __ ] delicious you had taco bell i
did
wow i know but it was to be fair it was
just bean and cheese
burrito and he said it was fantastic
there's other things there and this is
like saying you had a dunkin donut and
it was really sweet
yeah you didn't go to space with [ __ ]
jeff bezos i know
i i don't know how it was i got a story
for you and i want to see if you're
going to believe please be a good story
i want to see if you're going to believe
me though no answer is no no come on
dude
you know i fib but just just hear me out
i'm gonna tell you the story
i'm gonna tell you a story if that's
advice to chin on tr2 we don't want to
hear it
that's a different story everybody's
making fun of this morning
um i uh this is a story now
your job is to tell me and i'm going to
tell you if that's true or not no it's
that's not dude you got to give me okay
you know where i'm at so i i'm having a
conversation with a friend and i'm going
celebrity nowadays is a liability and
it's not worth what it used to be it's
not worth anything anymore
in a lot of ways and so i'm i get off
the phone and
i don't know my girl wants a bagel at
noah's bagels i don't eat bagels
anyway so the guy pulls up and he goes
he goes man dragon
yep and i go hey and he goes dude i'm a
huge fan and he goes
these are for you and he gives me
a pair of oakley sunglasses and he goes
i work for oakley
and i say to him this is crazy because i
was
on my way to buy my daughter a pair of
oakley sunglasses
because she plays tennis and i need her
to cover
and then he goes well i got you and your
whole family covered and he gave me
eight pairs of oakley sunglasses
for free and i was on my way to buy
oakley sunglasses
for my daughter and when i say oakley i
was going to go buy her oakley why
because i wanted the wrap-arounds and i
got some from my daughter
and my son and other people and so
uh is that story true the story is true
the man dragon thing's not true
okay that never happened okay now that
didn't happen now i like yeah i like
i'm sure you saw a guy with sunglasses
the story's true yeah and i have to
admit i can't remember if he said man
i think he did i feel like he did you
really have i added that in to see if i
would catch you on that but i don't know
the oakley's happened but i feel like he
called me man i feel like he did no
i got excited because i was like oh [ __ ]
it really happened i think he did
all right so you got oakleys
not such a good story huh but oakley's
are cool their clues are still great so
it's
not like a grand worth of sunglasses
yeah those are i was gonna say aren't
those like really expensive yeah shout
out to adam from oakley thanks buddy
thanks adam shout out to adam maybe i'll
bring some in for you guys
so i probably wouldn't i will not you
don't wear what do you what kind of
sunglasses do you wear
i don't you don't wear something oh yeah
i had it
but yeah i only leave them in the car
you don't feel like you need sunglasses
like don't you i can't believe
i can't go out in the sun because i've
had that lasik i can't leave that oh you
oh wow oh
my eyes are so sensitive to light yeah i
wear oakley on my bike
oakley still makes great songs they do
man they really do think they've ever
fallen off though wait lasik are you
good forever
no i think you have to give every 15
years daddy ain't had any uh lasik
i don't think i need it your eyes are
good right they are yeah you have good
eyesight i do
i can read i went to i went to monster
jam with the kiddos
first of all boston watched the entire
it was it have you ever been
it's it's the loudest thing in the world
i didn't wear earmuffs but
the kids did but boston watched the
entire thing with one eye
he forced me or his mom to cover one eye
why you'd only watch it because he's
scared
out of one eye he would just watch it
like this i think he's on my story chin
i'm just watching for three hours out of
one night oh is that him right there
hold on
joanna posted it oh my god
holy [ __ ] he looks different and look at
his little man bun
oh man bun dude full blown stevens do
the shobs the shob
have the hair game well you know what
jay doesn't
no jake but you and your dad have got a
and so that's how loud is you can't hear
any it's the loudest thing in the world
if 15 000 or 1500 you guys are pretty
close
that's amazing keep going chin
here it is solo
you would only watch it out of the one
eye
[Laughter]
and he would hold his mom's hand now you
you're you're one eye you're
when are you going to actually come out
as as a true mexican american man
i wish because that's a full blown
it's so loud oh yeah and how about they
i basically did the so i did like the
first pitch right this is so cute and i
i thought my
son would be like my dad took me when i
was a kid i thought it was a [ __ ]
i thought i'd be blown away by it dude
he didn't give a
[ __ ] he didn't care i'm like dude and
he's like dad let's get down
and miss the we're gonna miss the trucks
i'm like no dude they can't start til
your dad tells him to go
yeah he's like no they're gonna start
like dude yeah you work it you're gonna
be on tv dude and we see
they don't start to we say this is
monster jam
so i'm like just say it with me we get
done he's like let's get out of here my
god you ungrateful
i would have freaked the [ __ ] out if i
was five years old my dad did yeah
how long well i got three hours sir
three hours well there's intermission
like it's like trucks
and then they they gotta re-dirt
everything yeah yeah and then there's
the the motorcycle guys go which are fun
yeah that's right and then they bring
the trucks away it's three hours
it's good though dude oh and that whole
cantal culture they showed uh
john legend chrissy teigen and cetenaris
and so they showed john crowd didn't
recognize that all
little racist i think he's black and
then they showed chrissy teigen i was
like oh here we go she
oh they went nuts dude ah everyone went
nuts oh they love her yeah
love her wow that's so crazy because
when i showed her she was like oh
you could tell that's like and the crowd
went nuts oh wow no
not interesting that's surprising the
other ones doing fine i mean like you
know
how many people are really paying that
close attention
yeah maybe not that's interesting nuts
for a lot of people nuts for it
i looked up how much the and i those
monster truck drivers don't make
much no it's like 50 grand i think the
is that how much they
i wouldn't be on the show i'm surprised
to make any money for people
but i'm surprised to make any money i
mean they sell out everywhere they go
okay they're on the road like 200 days
of the year
all right you have 200 days a year but i
think like if you're
new it's like 50 grand but then like the
guy who drives the gravedigger you know
there's multiple drivers
so there's the truck but then in every
city it's a different driver typically
so they have a team of guys so i think
if you drive for like gravedigger
they're making like 200 grand
oh okay a show no no a year
a year come on dude that's a show i'm
driving yeah
yeah how much they're making my son had
uh his tenth birthday party
this weekend big 1-0 big 1-0 big party
kids everybody having a great time and
so
i got upstaged a little bit well i i
bought my son i showed up were you
trying to show off for the 10 year olds
well
i bought my son some a gift right so so
i be i buy myself oh you might be at
cyber
10 grand to 283 grand average salary 50
grand
okay so with the top 86 percent making
oh the top 86
so 86 percent makes 283 000 is that what
that means yep
and they just drive over stuff i mean
yeah
i mean he's got to be skilled you know
what i looked up you know people have
died
uh like uh kids have died from going to
monster jesus because they spit out you
know when they're doing like donuts they
[ __ ] spit out those rocks oh my god
so we were like
like maybe three rows back from the
front row but i just i was like man it's
this close and they're doing those
donuts and all the
rocks are spinning away so i googled
right there i'm like because anyone died
at monster jam
and some kid did oh jesus i think it was
a hot second ago yeah that would suck
that would suck so so it was in 1992
oh no that's much hmm
we can't imagine you go to monster jam
and you [ __ ] your kid gets hit with a
rock
yeah no so so i'm i'm
so it's time to open your gifts with my
my immediate family
and uh i get my son a an xbox controller
controller because he needed another one
and a pair of sunglasses
and then
i know not a great gift but you know it
is what it is
there right yeah so then he gets like a
lego set then he gets a chest
board from this and from one of his
teachers and this is you know stuff
damn teacher named [ __ ] yeah he's he
came to the the whole get-together
because he
you know he's homeschooled in his pod
with other kids so he's oh okay he's not
going to regularly
yeah so uh so then cheyenne who you know
fabricio and diana who owned viavanato
oh yeah their son how's that restaurant
doing it's killing it actually it's
killing it
but they made they did really well
during kobe because everybody's doing
takeout
but long story short i got my stuff
cheyenne shows up i got him a little
control he's like i get to play xbox now
with a friend oh yeah [ __ ]
cheyenne shows up with two giant like
he's holding on these two huge presents
these two [ __ ] huge things and i'm
like
he comes in late and just goes there you
go
and i'm like what the [ __ ] is this and
he goes open it crank
well oh and then then some other boxes
are there that he brings in
and he got him he made him essentially a
gaming console i didn't know shane was a
gamer
made him a [ __ ] gaming console this
huge thing so you can put his
huge monitor with a huge with a
custom keyboard without i i was
literally like my son was like take this
[ __ ] you get the [ __ ] out of here so
it's like i got a new dad
it's for computers well dude it needs to
don't room oh well it needs its own room
there's it needs uh he's got a creative
console yeah he created a
uh uh he's gonna create an addict in my
son the whole thing yeah the whole thing
was a disaster but i don't know how i
feel about that
how do i feel about my kid having at 10
years old that's hard to resist when you
got a huge monitor
that's what he's into right yeah but i
don't want my kid to be that into gaming
i mean they make a lot of money what
else is he into though not sports
he's playing lacrosse yeah yeah yeah is
he really you know hey
hey come on man hey hey come on
i know you want that for him but hey
it's funny because when you got
you got shop jeans like his son is like
really
indestructible there are some kids that
are like but if he's in the games
if he's passionate about it might as
well run with it yeah kids make a lot of
money though kids are making real life
yeah but it can also be an addiction and
you end up in your basement so let's be
honest how many kids are making money on
gaming right
uh there's a [ __ ] really
the point where comedians now are
streaming on twitch to try to get money
really yup yeah a lot of people are
streaming now yeah griffin is
crystalia chris
what you posted about what's he doing
playing video games what the [ __ ] does
chris play video games twitch is huge
and twitch has been huge for about
eight years christian here playing video
games yeah my son can start making some
money
because eric griffin when he was on the
show said that he made more money on
twitch
during the pandemic than he did during
uh like a regular comedy
year yeah well the one thing i'll say
the one thing
my kids went to coding camp and the
coding coding camp
yeah like it's a whole thing it's a
whole thing
but but but the kids that were teaching
coding
were and they were minecraft experts
they were 18 19 20 but they've been in a
room a dark room their whole life
and their bodies don't grow because
they're not
they're not eating a lot they're not
doing physical activities so their
bodies stay they stay
super small i mean your kids like to win
the olympia but yeah i mean just one
play some video games dude
yeah like they see their exercise they
got you know yeah they need to get out
my kids don't do that anyway they're
very they're athletic when they do stuff
but yeah i wouldn't shun the game and
stuff
no no man there's a lot there's a lot
in it the games are so i was watching
him play like some of those games are i
mean i'm such an old i'm such a dinosaur
some of those games are [ __ ]
unbelievable you're crazy and you play
with people you don't even know all over
the world makes me nauseous
like how to play the video game you're
not a video you're not a gamer
yes you know you never played like
golden knight dude that [ __ ]
game where the call of duty the call of
duty yeah that makes me nauseous you
know you're 54 right you know your mind
i'm saying can you get younger and
hipper is that
like how does brian i might be a little
hipper oh you know what makes me real
nauseous
that damn uh vr vr that one oh my gosh i
almost screwed my brain down
i played and reached for the ball if i
got it wasn't there oh you get hit and i
fell down i [ __ ] went and fell down
and hurt my
hurt this part of my hands those things
are dope
i went like that all right have you seen
the people who are doing like the fight
and they go to and they
run into the tv or some [ __ ] oh i got me
i gotta be so funny here's me boxing i
look like a complete idiot oh on the
virtual reality oh dude i'll send it to
china i just said
does it doesn't make you nauseous brian
yeah it does yeah see i told you i'm not
crazy
we're both 54. we're going to be well
ryan's 56
you're you're young dude i'm 34.
chappelle's lost some weight and you're
acting different now i am actually
here's the
fails yeah people get [ __ ] up doing it
is there the the there's the major wing
getting at best buy
i don't know what it's called oculus
ocus yeah my uh brother-in-law has it he
brings over for me and tiger there's
times people you play like scary games
with that [ __ ]
my girl did this i sent it to you and my
girl scent
you are in a weird what's he doing yeah
he has the i don't know what that's what
i was wearing
don't don't they have a drastic yeah
that's the main one don't they have a
jurassic park one and [ __ ] like that and
they have one where you climb
yeah like you walk off a ledge that's
all right
yeah that's the future for sure i'll
pick my brains out
hey i took your advice oh yeah oh no
yeah people are getting [ __ ] i don't
know those are my favorite
oh [ __ ] you got to be careful with this
stuff man
[Laughter]
dude yeah see [ __ ] that what's he doing
uh soccer you forget
you forget god damn i don't forget where
you're at though
you do man i did this happen to me
and that's what made me nauseous
dude i [ __ ] myself oh my god it's like
they're walking
this is so cool yeah it's cool maybe
we're in one
maybe let's go right to the [ __ ] tree
dude this [ __ ] is funny to me
[Music]
it is fun
have you done it no no i feel like you'd
like it
but i don't want to do this though
that's that's probably why i won't play
yeah
right is this boxing look at how this
guy boxes though look at this oh
[ __ ] oh no oh
he's
[Music]
i sent you my boxing one jen what what
advice did you oh
no that hurts you didn't stop it jen uh
your i took your game of thrones
advice i'm into it what do you think i'm
in love with it
it's great i'm in love with it yes i'm
also in love with old girl
all right uh what's her name uh khaleesi
here we go oh yes beautiful i didn't
know
jason momoa just took her down i was
like [ __ ]
i heard my girlfriend memorial well you
can
oh really no
why do you spoil that why would you
spoil why are you wrong
i know bro
it's like the one show where it gets
maybe having sex on there
and wait till you get to the gay sex it
was that was him it was gay dude they
get into it man
yeah he started so you started sucking
his ding-a-ling yeah it's great yeah
yeah after he just shaved his chest yeah
yeah damn imagine that
um
don't get used to him like come dude
uh what's this brian why's your shirt
off because i was i i didn't know what
was going on i
i was looking at four i didn't know i
was gonna get i didn't know i was
getting uh
videotaped and i'm freaking out look i
hurt my arms
i don't know what the [ __ ] to do
that's it i have another one i sent you
the wrong one all right
i sent you the wrong one i literally
made myself sore
no don't send it we're good
that uh how much i lost and so i got on
the scale but i was 277
and i'm at 255. shout out to kovan [ __ ]
yeah yeah it took away my [ __ ]
appetite i still can't
you still can't eat well yeah your taste
i i might no my taste is there
i can't eat like a big um big meal yeah
like i mean i had oatmeal today now the
point is for you not to put it all back
on i know yeah i can't put it don't be
going
what is it that you like to eat that
puts it back on is it nighttime that you
start eating
you can eat whatever you want no i'm
saying do you have a craving date
at night is that when you when you start
eating all the bad foods listen to that
dietitian
i don't brush no i don't know
everyone's like because i'm a little bit
i've become a little bit of that but it
doesn't but i heard
eating late at night or whatever the
hell doesn't really matter as long as
you're
tracking your [ __ ] yeah i'm not saying
you've been tracking your calories
yeah with the my fitness model yeah see
well i haven't since covet
yeah i couldn't really do it because all
i could do with you you're challenging
me
keeping that staying at 250. i haven't
been 250.
you're a little you're you're a little
candy eater at night no no
no no i thought you're a little candy
eater at night no not a sneaker sweet
candy sneaker really you used to be i
thought you'd eat oh yeah
yeah he's changed i like him have a
sweet tooth that's not too bad i enjoy
eating
dumb [ __ ] while i'm watching tv at night
okay i guess
yeah and i never used to have that and
now what are you watching on to
i watched i was watching uh love island
you like it i'm a little bit into trashy
tv now really used to make fun of that
stuff
i used to make fun of it all and now i
kind of enjoy it because it's
interesting
is it now it's just kind of like numbing
yeah
watch yeah what season you want i'm
watching
love island uk right now yeah yeah
that's the one that's the one which is
that's the one to watch live it's only
downhill from here it is
yeah they they get worse as they go well
how's the american one
trash it's awful don't only watch uk
only watch the australia is all right
but uk is definitely yeah
uk is the some of those accents i can't
even understand what the [ __ ] they're
saying sometimes
it's really interesting yeah
a lot of guys in on that show not maddie
i don't know everybody's in good shape
they're all young
young though yeah yeah they're they're
like early 20s yeah there's one where
there's a couple 30 year olds
there wouldn't know 30 year olds on
there
who who that i'm watching now i think
her name is joy maybe she
long black hair remember that one kirby
no she's not season five i think she's
like season two or something are you
with the twins
yeah curvy not a
where they're like who's the littlest
person in this how you know you're old
and you're way too old to be watching it
they're way too old let's not do that
anymore but there's uh they go
what's the oldest person you've hooked
up with and the girl's like i don't
really want to say this but 35
everyone's like 35 and you're
oh yeah man well my girl's 31 so she
watches it so i
watch it it's her fault is it her oh no
jesus
oh this is the newest season yeah the
thing about this show is that it just
[ __ ] goes
on it just like it's so how many
episodes well it's every week in the uk
like wednesday yeah it airs every day
every day
so it's huge yes a week
that's big gorgeous so it's going to
take a lot of time
and then the original host commits
committed suicide no she has so much
cash
no wait but what did she get hate from i
forget was she in a weird situation with
her
boyfriend at the time too the one with
the short hair though with the hair like
this
the blonde yeah yeah she was blonde yeah
suicide you're kidding me
that seems so crazy wow there's a 28
year old that's 29 too
wait why did she no they're 30 year olds
the the the one i'm telling you i mean i
just watched it
but why why did she commit do they
that's so nice yeah like social media
and
she was she was saying that talk city
from social media and then something
happened with her boyfriend like
there's the domestic dispute yeah and
then they called the cops on here yeah
they called the cops and was going to
come out in the media
and before she was supposed to go to
court over that and then she just
commits it with that
i know it's true there's no yeah there's
no 30 year olds oh my god
29 29 20. awful
there it is sophia that's her that's her
that's her
yeah she's beautiful oh there's one girl
that's the third trumper
season two oh this guy's awesome
what's up with this dude oh he's people
love season two though
he couldn't be stuffed to beat season
five marcelo okay more so
yeah this is the one i'm watching i was
watching martial
yeah no go to go to what was the one we
were five which one
which one's the best one five five five
after that's all
why did i started season six oh no we
started season six
i'm watching a friendship french
those twins those blonde twins yeah yeah
yeah i watched five six and then after
that it's just a [ __ ]
i do what else you got what else are you
watching i'm i mean i'm balls doing game
of thrones
okay i'm with the kids all day and
they're watching it over here wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait what season you want
right now season five
halfway through season five so how many
seasons is it eight eight
yeah i can't wait i can't wait yeah but
by the time i i the only tv i i get two
episodes of game of thrones tonight did
you like two hours of tv have you ever
seen
the have you gone down the breaking bad
rabbit hole no
one of the best shows ever i've heard i
watched the first two episodes
phenomenal yeah no not for you i gotta
re-watch it too because i got it i only
watched
i would highly recommend you stick with
it it only gets better i know people
love it and it kind of blows your mind
and it makes and it's almost it's
basically realistic
it really is you're like sure i would
watch it
i think it's i think it might be getting
into it i think it might be the best tv
show i've ever seen in many ways i
thought you like
you're a sopranos fan too right yeah but
i couldn't get it soprano's incredible
but i mean
it that's what started the whole tv
revolution but
[ __ ] uh but breaking bad was so
astonishing maybe because i'm an actor
and i've tried to write tv shows and i
see that writing and that acting it all
came together so perfectly mm-hmm
and they were just so good all the time
yeah people love breaking bad
i i definitely can't watch it now
because like that that actor on there
did that
shitty psa remember that from my wife oh
the
white guilt aaron paul like oh well
you're out of my friend's circle
now i can't watch anything you do
couldn't agree more it's like god
andrew schultz is so funny he's like who
the [ __ ] is this guy
and this guy that was the greatest one
he did that was
the fight all of you get the [ __ ] out of
here with your virtue signaling
get the [ __ ] out that was the weirdest
[ __ ] ever and you're not making a
difference
you didn't make a difference you [ __ ]
actors who are so out of touch to make
things worse oh
god they didn't do anything if anything
will make you racist it's those people
yeah
that made me hate white people oh god
that made me not want to be white
yeah first time ever now and now for
for nothing they should have just called
that a psa call oh
have you started watching the new uh
american horror yeah uh
i'm caught up right now on episode three
is it good
uh it's pretty good each episode is a
different storyline so like it's almost
like a
mini series within a minute you're
restarting
and that's why i got out i couldn't when
they came up with a new one
it's like true detective no i love that
no i'm talking about
no i love it i like how they switch up
the flavor every season but
every episode's different yeah so far i
don't know but i don't know if they're
gonna do a tie-in at the end for all of
them or not
but so far it's been three episodes the
first two
are of the same storyline and then the
third episode is a different one
so i think the next is going to be
different too i'm out
yeah so you still haven't watched gin
yet no i gotta watch
gin i keep forgetting no one's good i
saw it this weekend you saw it this
weekend
what'd you think i fell asleep my
girlfriend was able to watch the whole
thing
and we did not like it or you didn't
like it no it's just not for me
can i ask you this yeah did you can you
listen to it and you speak korean
fluently affluently but can you can you
understand everything they're saying or
no it's not
it's english oh it's in english it's in
english yeah yeah it's mostly like
yeah it's just just the the main actors
half korean oh okay
that's the only reason why he was
telling them to watch no
originally it's a korean movie but this
this one's new
damn you got to watch real korean movies
fell asleep i tried
but it was just kind of like slow and it
wasn't that scary what time did you
start it
like 11 p.m or something around there
yeah but she stood up for the whole
thing
i mean she was awake and she didn't like
it she didn't like it
what movies do you like jen i would tell
you to watch
old boy if you're gonna watch a korean
movie i don't i don't want korean movies
give me that's one of the best movies
ever what's that all right
what's up don't google anything about
the ending or whatever
you just watched one of the best movies
everyone craziest movies
it's like it's like a parasite right
yeah yeah yeah that's what personally
you
want
personally yeah yeah that's that's
korean style movies it's just as good
yeah and don't watch the american
version it's not good yeah it never
translates
the korean version is so astonishingly
good like
there's a korean movies they're great
for korean filmmakers especially
what what's what mainstream like uh not
korean chin
mainstream movie that i think movies are
showing you guys i mean honestly titanic
i thought was amazing
what happened
you get nothing from that guy i mean
i've
never heard anyone you can't you can't
get dirt deep
i mean
shovel out then he pulls out a drill
then he's got a jackhammer and he can't
get past the
[ __ ] layer all right and he can't get
to that
the man's asking a simple question
you're like jen
he
[Music]
good but like at the same time it looks
i don't know not good
it could either be really good or really
bad i agree i got to see it though gosh
i've never heard anyone
no no i just i just heard it was amazing
never heard anyone say that
yeah jurassic park
but you guys were you're talking about
current where they stand nice yeah
that's what he said like that's what he
was trying to get
watching these shows um
we watched that one japanese show but it
got cancelled terrorist
terrorism you're getting no interest
ask me what i did this weekend what'd
you do this weekend uh just
eight
catfish the first catfish movie the
movie catfish you guys watch that
no with how neve got started yeah yeah
yeah sure
sure you're working with him there's
nothing
i don't know what do you guys do at
night chin
yeah they play board games or some [ __ ]
sometimes we drink sometimes watch
movies
go to dinner do you all play board
movies oh wait went to the movies too
recently
we don't play board games oh would you
what did i see at the freaking movie
theaters
recently i'll get back to you on that
damn i totally forgot you guys went to a
movie marina six
the dining place yeah yeah and you live
in michigan you have a good food too
yeah you never seen a double date yeah
well definitely i'm really curious to
see what the [ __ ] is going on
so let's double date let me know take
brian is there any good korean barbecue
over there
he says i'll take his scope have you
been to scopa
i think he's been with us brad all right
uh i'll take you to uh
yeah we can go to world what what let's
go oh that's the
that's the korean barbecue place over
there yeah it's like in a small it's
actually good is it pretty good
good one yeah yeah really good have you
had korean barbecue
have i yes are you an adventurous eater
oh yeah i don't really care whatever i
can't i can't eat like a
shellfish though oh yeah that's
something is it guacamole
no i built my immunity that's right yeah
but uh shellfish yeah yeah i can't
yeah but i would love i love some good
uh restaurants
not i'm not a crazy picky eater no
well i ate too much chick-fil-a that's
probably what it got me
chick-fil-a that's nice that's what got
me to 277. that'd do it
yeah right yeah those [ __ ] fries it's
the sauces
it's too consistent i don't need to you
put sauce on chick-fil-a chick-fil-a
sauce
i know what you dip your fries in there
it's too cheap
yeah it's too good the sauce is no i
don't know i don't like the sauce i [ __ ]
with the polynesian
that's all sugar too i know it is also
right that's good that's how i got the
277. yeah
you have to stay away from there buddy i
know i can't do it all right jim what do
you got first
need clean all righty first oh wait hold
on
before we go please don't just watch
gotta get your take on the san hagen
oh how'd you get the shot what'd you
have i had tj i won money
you're welcome yeah thank you but um
uh i i i i thought that corey did most
of the damage
did more damage um so in that sense i
was i was
i wouldn't have been surprised if he had
his hand raised for sure could have went
either way
right but i did think that i do that
this is what i want to ask you
do judges score on ringmanship like
where you control the fight they do yeah
if you
if you have a if you're a trained eye
for it like it's pretty clear tj won the
fight
right because he was so tj tj won the
sport and
corey won the fight okay that makes
sense right it does but
in the sport the way it scored tj one
more rounds if you're scoring it as a
as a sport right you want more rounds
well i was surprised
octagon control stuff like damage
doesn't equal winning rounds
right i was surprised that he didn't
have an
answer for when he got behind cory
because cory was working the wrist he
had one leg
he had one leg that blew out his knee so
he couldn't
that's why he was doing it he's just
riding it winning rounds oh that's what
it was he couldn't twist
couldn't take him down there so how bad
why when bad it blew his knee up
and then that huge cut on his eye like
yeah did he did he tear any
yeah we don't know what yet but i just
touched him this morning you did
bad it's bad uh you know i think he'll
still be able to fight you know end of
the year
but that's one leg that's like but
that's but that's all control
that's all control yeah that's winning
rounds it's awkward it's all yeah yeah
it's thought gun control
he's good he looks phenomenal he still
looks great yeah
i mean he's fighting a killer he's
fighting a killer the ring rest was an
issue
his timing was off like it's good he
didn't fight peter young off the bat
yeah well peter yan is going to be a
nightmare for all of them i got him as
my champion for a long time
i don't think anybody solves that
problem tj can you after what he did to
al james sterling i i just don't i don't
see him i mean tj can beat him if it's
like tj's firing on all cylinders tj has
the
the right style to beat him for sure
well what's interesting is tj comes
forward and so does peter young
so they're going to be back they're
going to be standing there up close and
personal
well one of them one of them's uh a
collegiate wrestler
well one of them is a russian guy with
with crazy hips
and so good luck taking peter yon down
right so it's going to be interesting
and his
i think his striking is that it's he
seems to have that
subtle that subtle the subtle inches
that russian whatever he's doing
it's pretty big pretty rudimentary
it looks it looks super crisp and
perfect as
i mean he's but you know what you're
getting you know what you're getting you
know where you're getting so you can
game
for tj that's good yeah tj's a [ __ ]
nightmare
he's a two and a half year layoff man
san hang on one leg one eye
you beat course hand hanging with one
leg one eye that's all you gotta know
that's [ __ ] incredible and he was
going to fight
the winner peter yon al jermaine if
there has been a clear-cut winner
is there gonna be his first fight back
is there gonna be a rematch with jan and
algerman
before that happens yeah well they're
they're fighting in october
yeah i i got my i got peter young i
don't know how you solve that problem he
just
out for al jermaine it's a nightmare but
for tj it's a good fight
yeah it is a good fight would you put
money on tj at
that fight yes
tj's very hard to bet against in general
one leg
him as a dog man i was like god i like
money too yeah i'm a bad bet
i just hate ben against corey all right
what do you got jen all right
first one so this is something you sent
to chin and i to bring up
um there is a tick tucker who is balding
and he likes to wear the equivalent of
today's toupee here we go he likes it
here we go
don't say this stuff having a hairpin
thinks it promotes
confidence in men who are balding scroll
down this kid look at that kid's balding
no look at him
wow he looks like he's like 20 something
he's balding
that's the look of his hair now look at
that him that's terrible it could be you
brian nope
it's not gonna be me you're not gonna do
a little hairpiece no look at that dude
no that's a little kid a toupee oh
that's a little
legit does that look though dude yeah
look that's basically just yeah
i'll do it for this [ __ ] podcast i
think you should do it but i don't i
don't really appreciate how much i think
i need that right now
you know you need that i look good for
this angle dude
your hair's getting thinner by the month
it is i gotta get back on the on my
hands that's no
it's that's too late you should how much
is this chin
how many something like this it probably
depends on where you go
because like they cost oh you can get it
anywhere different the person installing
it
i think they got i think they glue it on
and it's never happening
and he's blown up like he was only doing
two or three but since he went viral on
tick tock now he's doing a bunch dude
the guy that actually did that's the
earplugs range from four thousand
fifteen thousand
i'll go get those again and see if they
work the second time
no a hair piece can go with the stick
docker gotcha
i don't know man i'm not doing that and
i don't really
scroll down it says the hair piece can
go without a touch-up for just four to
six months
that's hilarious and it just it's it's
it's probably glued to your head how do
they do it keep scrolling down oh sales
at pr
it's in la increased 30 you shut up
we're doing upwards of 10 to 16 replays
so maintenance appointment
big increase from five to six i'm not
doing it you're right you're questioning
950 bucks dude i'm not what if we
sponsor it
you can go [ __ ] off i'm not gonna go get
my [ __ ] hair shaved my head shave and
then they glue that on me
no you'll keep what you have which you
can glue it on top
no no they gotta cut that so i gotta
wear it
i wear a [ __ ] hat they gotta they
gotta cut more than a hat
you gotta [ __ ] off them never do it the
next time you get bored and
cut your hair yes and buzz it up i shave
i might shave my head you wear hats
no i don't look so good in hats oh i've
never seen anything okay see one of
those gay like beach heads if i wear
them backwards
right and if i want to keep this playing
tennis
no i don't play like that though don't
do the net hat no don't do that
i come over the ball like that but look
at this guy dude that's what i'm saying
i saw this i'm like [ __ ] this would be
so good for kyle
you can go [ __ ] off all right because i
don't appreciate that look at him though
he's young that's the tough part too
because well he should just shave
the sides no but you can't because
that's how you do the fade so you have
to cut your hair like you're balding
right on top
oh and put it on top and then fade it up
yeah well i think they cut his hair that
way
you have to be this way let me see the
after channel there's that
wow oh my gosh and it looks great
it looks like it's his [ __ ] hair you
spoil somebody pulls it up and sees
the this one is dope who's gonna run up
and pull your hair people
that's legit as [ __ ] people are not
gonna run before you yeah who's gonna
pull your hair
first of all you [ __ ] i'm not doing it
unreal
i thought this was so light you need you
said you do you just said you'd do it
for the podcast
when that happens no i won't they they
might be able to clone her in about five
six years
you know 60 something well whatever i am
dude we don't have to get in my age
whatever
i'm gonna look good though you won't
even consider this 950 bucks
no i won't i'm not wearing i'm not too
pay guy dude
that's not a toupee this is different
you know when you're getting older
the last thing you want to do is dumb
[ __ ] like that i already got my lids you
did your eyes
i did these guys that was because my mom
told me that
that i it it was it was just looking
your mom didn't impress you then i got
it that's all you dude
no my mom said you should get it either
your mom or your girl
no it's my mom she got it done and she
said in our family we get these heavy
lids and i was getting it
and it looked stupid and she goes and
it'll get out in the way of your
eyesight do it now when nobody notices
so i did it and this is an easier
process than that in the lid if you're
going to do the lids the
younger lids that were painless but it
was a bit of a [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah
plastic surgery and i thought the other
day i was like well i've had two
procedures
major procedures on my head eyes and the
the slice them
back yeah now they take just pieces
that's what i'm saying there's no
there's no
transplant didn't take oh god
oh god that is awful this was one of
when it was uh
oh god i look great there don't i
look right look at my face
jesus christ holy moly
i had to get laser treated hollywood
because the blood was
pooled there that's what i was going to
ask yeah
that's a tough look huh look at my look
like a bug look at my egg head i used to
be cute
as you get older your face starts to do
weird [ __ ] with gravity man i was a cute
kid
i looked at pictures when i was younger
and i was i was all right you look good
right now great brian you look great
right now
don't don't bother me i just think you i
think you i'm looking
i just think uh that two-page stuff
would [ __ ] take you next level
no surgery no surgery you've already
done the eyes dude you're
you're so hollywood you've already done
the eyes you already have the huge scar
down the back here
look at me right now i'm not afraid of
you
and i'll come at you come at me with
toupee though
i can do it i actually i know exactly
how corey sant hagan does at me
perfect and i want you to do that with a
wig
i'll do that with my guy even if i pay
for it
even if you pay for it in a [ __ ]
hat didn't your mom not having a hot
glue gun
yes she did i'm not having a haircut
around the eyes i don't listen to her
i listen to her on the eyes she's saying
because i'm a little vain
but i'm not wearing a hair hat for six
months because you think it'd be
nifty daddy's already done two cosmetic
surgeries okay
that's where we have to draw the line
and this ain't the surgery this is
[ __ ] whoop
no i'm not doing any of that [ __ ] all
right i tried i wouldn't mind getting my
face like uh like peeled
what you know what i mean where your
skin looks because you get like
chemical peel or yeah well you get like
because you get like um
i've never had a facial or anything i
mean i did once when i was wearing
makeup all the time somebody told me to
go but
i've never done that where they do an
extraction and stuff what
don't do that dude no i won't who told
you i don't know i'm just i'm not gonna
do it you you're gonna get mad i'm lazy
with [ __ ] like this
i can't wear cologne you buy me clone
i'm not gonna wear it you buy me face
creams i'm not gonna wear
i just i'm lazy with it i can't i can't
primp
i'm looking forward to when you can
actually grow
hair that's gonna happen
chemical peels [ __ ] up your face though
your face all red for a few don't do
that
please don't do that anybody i don't
know who's talking about peels you can't
go outside for
a few days it's recommended that like
your face doesn't get exposed to any
sort of sunlight because it's so
sensitive afterwards
so you need to stay indoors why would
you do it i wouldn't do it
it's just something to say but you won't
get in here i'm not getting a hairpiece
i'm not getting [ __ ]
i'm not typical i work out and i and i
don't drink alcohol
we have all the fighter in the kids fans
sign it for you to get the hairpiece
would you do it then i'm not doing it
you're not gonna do it i might get a
tattoo i've been saying that forever but
i don't know what to give up on that no
we did a t5k tattoo would be cool no no
a hairpiece would be cool
i'd rather you get that than
get a little t-fat k right here
something like that yeah just on my back
yeah just a big backpack back all right
what else you got jenny he's not getting
the [ __ ] in here because we tried
good good work team we did our best we
did we tried
was that a whole thing you were going to
try to do yeah we had a whole
conversation about it yesterday
okay so the norwegian women's the beach
handball team basically the volleyball
team
for norway got fined recently because
they refused to wear the bikini bottoms
while they were playing and they wore
regular like um board shorts instead
it's the same type of board shorts that
the
men's team usually wears but they were
fined i believe 175 dollars per player
who didn't wear
175 yeah oh no
it made a bunch of news because they won
bronze in their league
but they got fined for it because they
didn't want to wear something they won
bronze at the
olympics yeah yeah and i don't blame
them for feeling that way why the [ __ ]
shouldn't they be able to wear shorts
the way it guys do
like you make them wear can you get they
were just saying that they feel more
comfortable wearing shorts and
performing so like yeah
is there some rule though that they yeah
it's like that's their uniform oh they
wore those spandex instead yeah i'm a
fan of those
and they're actually that isn't it i'm
not even thumb but like a bikini bottom
like a swimsuit
oh is that what they have to wear let me
see that oh i know this is what they
chose
this is for the beach beach volleyball
and they got fine for it
yeah here's my thing so leading up to
this
they were cool with it but then they get
to the olympics and now they're not cool
with it
yeah why now what do you mean you say
they so they play
that's what they played in when they uh
performed
right when they were actually competing
in the olympics in the olympics i'm
saying prior to that right they have to
wear bikinis
yeah now they get to olympics like we're
not wearing bikinis anymore i don't know
if
this was an ongoing issue following up
to the olympics and they just decided to
make that change then and there or if it
just kind of
it probably was talked about enough i
would imagine right
yeah i don't think this is a decision
that necessarily came overnight but this
is the first time that
pink pink paid their fines yeah and pink
found out about it and said i'll pay
your fines and that's what they wanted
them to know
that's usually what they were serious
athletes look at these
so that's usually what they wear and
then they get the olympics and they want
to switch it there's always that one
spotter who's shorter than everybody
else huh
so bravo norwegian not bravo my thing is
is
this where it gets dicey right like you
so you're playing beach volleyball is
that is it or handball what the [ __ ] is
they playing
they call it volleyball beach handball
so beach so you're playing beach
handball
for years in this bikini
so you're playing bikini in this and
then you get the olympics and now you're
upset you want to swear
handball isn't that what you signed up
for
yeah i know it's what you signed up for
yeah what it came down to was this
that's the thing when people say you
have to wear this and men can wear those
they kind of go wait a minute you're
saying i have to
no that's kind of what happens right and
it's like why
well that's because that's girls have to
wear that uniform
and it's like i get all that my issue
with it is you've played hand
i'm sure they've all played handball
since they were kids you get to be an
olympian
and then you get to olympics and then
now you have a problem let me see what
the men wear
they wear well men can't be no the men
were the speedos can't put that dude
i mean no you can't have speed yeah the
dudes aren't wearing speedos
no they were on the uh right here
oh okay um should allow them to wear
what they want my only thing is
doing it during the olympics i know what
you mean i know
oh you know i know exactly what you're
talking about yeah
i mean by the way norway and if you look
at
statistically they couldn't be more
about equity
there are laws in the books with norway
where men and women have to represent
you know they'll essentially like you
can't have a public company without
women on the board and all that what's
really interesting about norway though
in sweden and scandinavia in general
is that when they when they enforce
these equity laws essentially because
it is considered widely among social
scientists to be
the most equitable society in terms of
like
male and women roles so
what's fascinating is that they they
were like well there are so many women
nurses and no male nurses there's so
many
male engineers and no women engineers
well when you make these rules when you
when you have
this really equitable society shitty
male nurses no what happens is it's
really fascinating
what happens is men go to engineering
anyway and women go to nursing anyway
so in fact there are more women nurses
than there are and there are more male
engineers because
if you let people actually make their
choices when everything's equal
what you will find this is going to
sound like a big surprise is biological
males
tend to gravitate toward certain
professions that women are not
interested in sure so psychology and
things that have to do with like people
women tend to be in
nursing care men gravitate toward things
like engineering yeah dangerous more
risky stuff correct which is why
it just naturally goes there that's why
and they they work men tend to work
longer hours they tend to work
riskier hours all those things and they
tend to be less agreeable and more
competitive in some ways
like i'm saying generally so what you'll
see is you'll see men making more money
because they're putting in more hours
the idea that in western countries like
europe the united states
there's that women don't get paid as
much that women
if they're doing the same job as men get
paid three quarters is a lie
that's not true that does not if you
look at the other factors that are
controlling that then then
you can see why but the fact that it's
due to discrimination
no longer holds water in this society
and certainly not in europe yeah that's
interesting
yeah but it's interesting that men and
women kind of gravitate toward different
things makes sense though of course it
does
of course it does you know what's weird
when i went to school for audio
engineering
it's like almost all guys that's right
like a couple of women but it's also not
like a risky job it's kind of more like
attention to detail so i thought they
would like that but no men are men tend
to be
that's why software engineers a lot of
software a lot of tech
it was it was a boys club it was men
were
naturally drawn toward that now there's
this big push
to get women and but the guy robert
dannemore or james danimore got fired
he was a really good software engineer
and all he did was he
circulated an internal memo looking at
all the science to try to help
answer the question of why more women
are not in
yeah software you know uh computer
software stuff
and he went through he looked at the
science it wasn't his thing he just said
here's what the scientists who studied
this say
and he got fired for creating a
dangerous work environment
he got fired by by the ceo for creating
a dangerous work environment also don't
react like that
um
so what else
okay so i saw this and thought of you
the unreleased sample for the travis
scott with
uh fragment was released
i just okay cool about it
what's the difference guys i know i
can't tell you blue white and black not
very original
the swoosh is backwards design in the
back heel
what is it looks like a dragon ball
almost yeah what's the swoosh oh here it
is
that's the trademark of scott collab
okay
and then the lightning bolt is fragment
on the back brandon what do you think
system
those are fire they'll be impossible to
get so whatever
really yeah because brokers buy them up
they're just not gonna release many it's
gonna be like a super collector's item
those are sick though
all right so two girls in jersey
go on a amusement park ride a slingshot
where
you're basically like like a rubber band
and then you fly up into the air
while they're flying up in the air at 75
miles per hour
pigeon somehow lands on one of the girls
so funny
is she okay yeah yeah
that's a dead [ __ ] pigeon
i have it so quick i've never done one
of these things
i have no desire to it
we get her fixed
i feel like the bird's okay though yeah
i think they're birds okay
holy [ __ ] and she just pulled that
[ __ ] off
oh jesus christ the face when it lands
but at least the bird didn't freak out
i think the bird might be alive yeah
that wasn't like does it keep going or
that's it
yeah he got all [ __ ] up yeah a goose
that's a lot of meat yeah
he got [ __ ] up goose is a big [ __ ]
bird [ __ ] yeah
all right apparently there's been some
uh bad flooding in germany mm-hmm
and in europe as well and then this
particular reporter
went to a scene and grabbed mud and dirt
and put on her clothing
to make it seem like she was actually
volunteering to help it's a bad
situation hilarious no this guy caught
it on video
it's this girl right here
it's hard to see though right she's
acting like she's like in the trenches
yeah
and then her news station even said like
they applauded her for her help well
it's like
do you ever see when anderson cooper's
doing the hurricane
and he pretends he's like in waste high
water but
like the camera like pans over and like
everything's safe and calm
but he like went into this like pond
what yeah everyone's like what are you
doing dude
oh wow that's so embarrassing
remember when there's the looters in
santa monica and those instagram models
and they'll take pictures yeah yeah
like helping clean it up and they have
video of that girl like grabbing a
hammer and then she takes picture and
jumps back in the mercedes
oh yeah damn
same same sort of stuff so kyle showed
me this last week
it's just supposed to be funny because
of uh connor's cast
the way his cast looks
just a major class
looks like he came from recess in the
school nurse like doctored it up
yeah look at this very professional boy
our boy justin is so tattooed is that
mummy leg
damn oh damn the beeps hanging out drink
something with them loafers
that's cool cool a lot of these are just
instagram posts so here's another one
someone we got tagged a lot in this one
i guess this has an ass
yeah because you had to cut the tails
thick cheeks instead this is bobby's
born without a tail he's giving thick
cheeks instead oh boy wow god damn damn
[ __ ] huge thank you i bet he got his
tail bit off by another [ __ ]
where he's born without it just has
these huge maybe but it looks like he
got it caught in a [ __ ]
a motorboat or some [ __ ] i think you got
to see it
looks like he's built i mean other other
[ __ ] uh other
got the wagon and crocodiles and gators
will just bite each other
on the leg twist and take that [ __ ] off
yeah just take it right off
shit's so crazy all the time that's it
i think he was going through i feel like
he was born without a b
okay he was born without a tail yeah i
guess he was born with that one poor
little guy
so thick you probably can't swim
we probably can't swim like this i don't
think he can no that tail
does a woman oh wow
it's a female alligator poor little
thing so she's thick cheeked oh that's a
female
oh okay
um okay so i'm sure you guys know right
now that australia is locking back down
again
wow right and so there's a bunch of
protests on the streets
and then boss protests because they're
locked down yeah they're all thrown up
it's a ton posted protesting
so boss logic posted this oh wow
check this out the guy juggling or
something yeah shut the [ __ ] up
so when you reach the final boss at the
lockdown protest dude that
talk about a man dragon that's a [ __ ]
man driving there
maybe i'll start blowing that looks like
a movie right bro he took this as his
time to shine that's a great he can blow
something i got an audience
so so they're pissed they're locked down
they're locked down hard
yeah people are just sick of it man i
mean come on
we've had enough we've had enough and
especially since people are vaccinated
then it's like people aren't dying like
if you go to the hospital because you're
a little sick i'm like all right you'll
be all right
yeah you'd be all right yeah yeah they
just told me to ride it out
yeah that's all they said it's like
anyway oh what's this
i don't know how legit this is but hold
on oh this is pretty cool
this
i'm hot don't tase me that [ __ ] just
stings
[Laughter]
my safe word is pineapple juice cross
your ankles
cross your ankle take pictures bring
your ankles up to your butt
swap man what's my safe word that's
[ __ ] right there yeah that's how far
i go
you think i'll get pilates
you got to give it up to this guy
why are they teasing them i don't know i
don't know how real this is either
because he's an [ __ ] for doing it oh
that's cute
oh that's cute i like it
look at this no don't do that that's oh
that's that's my lighter
it don't work don't do drugs kids this
guy's hilarious
he is funny give him a give him a little
something for being funny
why'd you have to [ __ ]
i like this guy
[Laughter]
unless you want to see a big
by the way by the way though that was
why did he tase him like that that was
true
probably because he had did you see that
one with like that one police officer
uh planning drugs did you see that oh
yes i am
i think they had video of it like the
cop cam yeah and it showed that he just
pulled it out of the front and put it
back into the back oh okay
and then and people are covered yeah
okay that's cool all right all right
good
sorry is that action bro oh yeah i got
you they got it that's how fake news
they're going
i don't know that's how the fake news
rolls dude yeah it does
that's right yeah that's action
bronstein sorry everybody
who is that action bronson action
brother he's sure too
yeah i don't know who that is he's at
240. so i'll show you a picture of him
before
he has that show [ __ ] that's delicious
but he got big because he's he's a
rapper
okay he's in new york do you think uh
king of staten island
he's not known for that though you know
where's a good one a good friend he's
lost a lot of weight
that was him before hunaway wow good for
him chappelle who's he in kingston
island he gets shot the guy
takes him to the hospital
he kind of has a cameo right no it's a
big role
[Music]
yeah no one know him from that though no
he looks [ __ ] great man that's
amazing
he's also wrong says no one smoked more
weed on his show than him ever
really yeah he smoked rogan under the
table yeah
i liked his videos he's a chef too like
he was a rapper but his
his passion is food so is that [ __ ] that
delicious show
it's on vice it's great it's him and his
boys eating good food
good for him man that boy's still thick
yeah he's built like a fire hydrant huh
yeah
i feel like it's been like that i feel
like a baby rhino like an alligator with
no tail
i always say if you're a thick dude get
[ __ ] tatted on your stomach man
yeah that takes away from the fat on the
stomach it looks cool once you're like
kind of you got that gut and then you
got
that powers out [ __ ] on it shit's dope
you don't mind a gut if he's got stuff
on it
uh i don't mind a gut if he has the
confidence that comes with it
like some fat guys who just like know
how to rock their [ __ ] are hot as [ __ ]
he does maddie matheson maddie
matthewson gives me that price
there's some guys who roll with it yeah
yeah they don't shy away from
the girls like that yeah and this is
kevin holland
this is for reminding me chappelle so do
you know
derek brunson the ufc fighter used to be
a cheerleader oh wow
and he beat up kevin holland they posted
this afternoon
brunson was a three-time dividend one
all-american wrestler north carolina
yeah he cheered in college or
competitors yeah scholarships high
school leading and wrestling
damn cheerleading a hell of an athlete
yeah
that's dope so that's cool to know
and then yeah that thing saw this
they're so cute
obviously it's a voiceover good morning
oh my god i'll kiss that thing i know
and then here's another video
thing is so [ __ ] cute hippo weak dude
hippo so they thought that this fawn
was invading its territory so they just
destroyed it that's right they're super
super territorial
super they're so great they will kill
them the thing is already dead
yeah they said you know what can you
swim like this let's find out
and they don't eat it they just killed
others in the area they're vegetarians
that's right they just [ __ ] kill it
oh my gosh
yeah also fond what are you doing dude
chain transitions
i know that's what supposed to them
murdering a deer
this is this is the hippo week this is
what you get
hippos are different suck no hippos are
cool dude yeah but they're so they're
such [ __ ] they just kill a ton of people
they're just aggressive as [ __ ]
yeah you can't go in a boat you cannot
be in a smaller boat than them or they
will [ __ ]
hit a week hippo week take it discovery
channel yeah
i'm giving you hippos kill the most
people right yeah i don't know if that's
true i think
well we looked it up they didn't yeah
the most aggressive mosquitoes kill them
mostly water water buffalo kill a lot of
people too
i've been close to hippo really i forgot
that we did that we looked it up with
john
it was in the top ten or whatever though
hippo's number one hippo's number one i
mean as far as killing human beings
mosquitoes
obviously but i mean that doesn't really
count they're the most aggressive out of
all the animals hippos
yeah more than a water buffalo yeah yeah
i don't know they both kill more people
don't get
between them and the water i guess but
whatever that means
eat deer eat sometimes deer will eat
meat
deer will eat birds that are stuck in
fences it's weird
and bunnies yeah
just go where it says what animal kills
more humans than any other
mosquito number one snakes number three
oh yeah snakes that's right
dogs dogs make sense but then when you
think bugs i'm not thinking
i'm thinking of actual animals the
problem with this is though we're
like yeah obviously we have more
interactions like tapeworms
we have more interactions with dogs yes
yes
yes exactly crocodiles and hip hippos
500 crocodiles a thousand
[ __ ] that's a lot crocs are so
[ __ ] scary because they just they're
just ambush predators
mosquitoes though real problem you don't
you see how fast when that that cheetah
got taken by that crocodile yeah
i mean it's so fast that if a cheetah
isn't getting out of the way you ain't
getting out of the way god no
just how the [ __ ] are freshwater snails
killing people
i think they carry some kind of a weird
disease oh because you gotta eat them
yeah scorpions make who's eating wait
freshwater snails kill 20 000 people a
year
dude if i die by freshwater snail just
tell my kids i died by a shark yeah
uh so espn is posted this again yeah
i'll just play it's a memory of this
girl who knocked this girl in seven
seconds
seven seconds seven seconds yeah poor
girl it's just right out of the gate she
goes at her
this is quickly
why isn't that girl fighting back she
got stung early
jesus christ one of the quickest
knockouts in women's boxing history i'm
in boxing history period
it dude like you didn't know she was
damn her controller wasn't even pulled
it's like someone dropped the controller
come on give me a second
god she got [ __ ]
um so brennan i try to get this article
but
you have to be a subscriber to yahoo
it's usa today i kind of didn't be able
to read it or not
i mean i i didn't memorize it on top of
my head you couldn't find anywhere else
because it this is the word the article
came from weird i don't because i don't
subscribe to
i gotta say why is that on usa today i
don't know watch i click on it
i even tried signing up but it i gotta
pay 499 a month weird
i want to send you something that's a
shame yeah
all right what else you got that's not
going to work then yeah i didn't
perfection but it makes sense very
the perfectionist nature of bodybuilding
you're just talking about how many guys
eating disorder
dysmorphia from like trying to get in
shape and how they
they get like uh eating yeah any
disorder yeah
that makes sense and then that's my
favorite is the term they have it's
called
bigomorphia where you like even like
that bodybuilder can't get big enough
guys who are big you just stay on your
cell phone brad no i'm trying to find
some guys who are like real big
like they it's never enough yeah so they
become addicted to the gym
it's called i think big mega morphia
yeah because
because like even like phil heath looked
in the mirror like [ __ ] man i'm so small
just a form of dysmorphia bigorexia
that's what it's called i love that name
bigger yeah
we shard a club called bigorexia
constantly about building muscle on your
body yeah nothing's good enough oh i'm
saying something
that's weird huh
oh my god i was talking about it with uh
mark harley i sent him this article he's
like yeah
i think a lot of it comes from too is
like because mark's around my age is
like we grew up our heroes were like
arnold schwarzenegger
sylvester stallone like that was the
epitome of health like those
jack big guys it's like every guy
thought that's what you have to look
like
and like carries over and even then now
you say arnold's son is freaking
have you seen his son lately the you
know the one that he had sex with the
name look great
he's jacked yeah he's he looks like his
dad's jeans
yeah his same face he's tan because he's
mexican he's the big chest like his dad
bring him up chin he's jacked who is it
arnold's uh
not on instagram no so i'm gonna look at
brian's gonna do brian's first year i
just want to see this guy who's
he's a stud who's uh who's such this is
hilarious
these memes of the romans this [ __ ]
dude we were talking about
studs dime pieces and guys who can do
[ __ ] watch
um hold on where's there's there's one
where he does
i think it's that one wait this one it
might be or it's
he's doing some crazy [ __ ] no
no he's like [ __ ] just bring up a bee
boy
no he does some crazy [ __ ] venice
yeah i've seen this before there was one
thing go go there that's it go down
bring it that one right there on the
right no on the right
right on the right you [ __ ] right there
watch this dude watch this [ __ ]
wait
watch this wait wait come on come on
that is very high yeah that's all good
but he does some crazy
oh my god all right now well i have this
shin what else you
[Music]
i forget it just forget it i like how i
was like wait he's good he's good
no looking here he's doing push-ups no
sweet man he's getting
it just erase that please is this him
right here that's him dude
looks just like his dad just like his
dad that's the famous picture oh look at
that
handsome guy pro joe too handsome dude
look at him on the [ __ ] horse
he has the wide shoulders like his daddy
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
he's starting to look like his papa huh
yeah
and it would be weird if you're because
he has his
his sons with his wife right patrick
schwarzenegger
yeah like he's like you know kind of a
beta male like
he's like a skinny actor type yeah when
your dad's arnold [ __ ] swears
he's got and then your dad has sex with
the maid and
[ __ ] boom and that's what he's just
freaked how crazy look at that he's ill
dad he got his dad's [ __ ] genetics
that's [ __ ] crazy he looks just like
him isn't that dope
in the water
yeah i mean you've seen arnold at 16 or
14 when he's natural
he looks like that it looks natural
he's getting there man damn
it's crazy now his dad is just like hey
dude this is what i did here
try that out yeah i wonder if
hollywood's gonna come knocking
he looks [ __ ] like his papa though
man yeah
still not as well as his dad at 14
though
no how old is he he's young man yeah
early 20s i'd say dude he's a spitting
image of his dad
yeah it'd be hard to hide like you want
to tell me something
i mean he was only 23. it was going to
come out yeah you know
and then you look at it the patrick
schwarzenegger it's like
patrick looks more like his mom well
magic patrick said
he's a big kid he's a bigger kid it's
just tough when your dad's
oh there it is okay that's he's a stud
stuff when your dad's on sourcing you
know yeah yeah
i mean look there's a lot of that's a
lot that's a kid's a looker and then
your half mexican brother is
jack city and he looks pretty jacked
he's
looks like he's tall is arnold pretty
tall
uh six one six one six one all right
i mean you know not bad
not bad good and what's arnold's mexican
uh kid's name joseph bana when i heard
that rumor
i remember i was like it was during the
gray davis recall and i was like
[ __ ] this is such [ __ ] they come
up with this stuff
no he would never have to get his maid
pregnant and then be running for that
doesn't make any sense boom well think
again kids
think again is that gina carrano no
that's not hannah
sorry close enough that's a giant
catfish
i just saw some breaking so i just want
to see well there's a little there's a
rumor
and i'd like to get your your [ __ ] on
this rumor
well when is it says it's november to be
determined
official day and venue uh i got
i have a i have did you hear this rumor
about jake paul who might fight
connor anderson silva no no logan paul's
in fight i'm sorry
that's right man logan paul yeah
interesting
what do you think of that one good fight
good fight
people will watch for sure the kids will
make money
i think anderson's going to destroy him
i mean ashland just beat the show
caesar chavez jr he's a real boxer oh he
did yeah
oh it's a tough fight for logan yeah
yeah to say the least
depending what the rules i didn't know
that he just beat the [ __ ] out of there
you know yeah no next kid's speed is
a real box yes yeah beat his s wow how
many rounds
12 rounds jesus christ i did not know
that
wow and that was in shawna's hometown
so the scorecard how old is mr silva 42
43 um i told logan if he's gonna fight
uh anderson make sure there's drug
testing
46. uh well i feel like at 46 we should
be allowed to take a little something
something
don't you against a 23 year old can
logan take something
no because he's 23. well no you can't
have one guy yes you can
you want okay so one guy so one guy's 23
years older
how old is logan paul 25 25.
okay so one guy's 21 years older so
don't fight
dude no hold on so so he's just bringing
some answers and silva should be
bringing his his levels up to where you
know not even where logan's
are but silva's been fighting forever
he's newer to the
world i understand but 46 46
probably probably similar yeah both
around six two six three
you know what i'm saying no i don't
should all sports should do that when
you're fighting somebody who's
46 in an exhibition i have no problem
then if you need that to compete then
you should probably shouldn't be
fighting those are the rules
because you can't create exempt
exemptions for guys with
low testosterone you open up the
floodgates
i think if it's a if it's for something
like this i think it'd be fine
for instance silva i do but logan can't
touch it uh-uh that's stupid
well he doesn't need it think about it
he's physically 25
okay for the prime of his life
hormonally right okay so let's play this
game brian
so let's say logan gets tested even
though he's 25 years old
his testosterone level is 400 so
anderson takes stuff to get to what
level is okay with you
well i don't think i don't think logan
would be 400
you have no idea you have no clue what
your time on so let's say hi let's say
his level was 400
well he'd have abnor abnormally no that
would be normal
no the level's 300 a thousand i i think
typical 25 year old like that has got to
have higher testosterone
so you're assuming it's high
testosterone but neither of us know so
let's say it's that 400
right i don't know normal level right
but no i know you don't think dude
yeah let's say it is 400 right and and
simply go to 500 yes
but logan has to stay at 400 100 percent
you know why
very simply because there is something
called age
reaction time that's like all those
that's why you retire
well because what's the first thing
together he has retired this is an
exhibition he hasn't retired this is an
executive ocean
that hasn't retired brian he's still but
this is a boxing match
he's mostly an mma fighter this is a
boxing match hold on this is going to be
fun to watch
hold on logan is not a professional hold
on hold on hold on it's not an
exhibition
he fought julius caesar chavez for 12
rounds of professional battle yeah
okay but this is still what would we
consider a
an exhibition round a fight technically
right because logan's not a professional
i don't think it would get sanctioned
would it or i guess it has to be if it's
i think no that would have to be
it would have to be eight rounds right
but it would be weird to say you can
i just think when you're i just think
when you are 25 and you're fighting a 46
year old there is a
huge difference when it comes to you
know age right so
speed that's why guys retiree yeah but i
still want to see them fight
because you see you have a great you
have a great one you would never have
anderson
silver fighter in his prime doesn't make
any sense but now i'm a little intrigued
now because anderson's holder he's 46.
i'm intrigued he fought me and he's
fighting a young really athletic
kid who can hit hard and he's not a bad
boxer and very good athlete right but no
now i know i'm like i'm like but no
commission's gonna go this guy can take
stuff this guy can't no matter what the
age is
yeah i i think though what i what i to
be really honest because
what what for so for tj's 35 yeah
corey's 26.
right their testosterone would be
different tj well that you can't take
stuff
that's a that's a that's a professional
fight what i would say
what i think what i'm saying here is
that i want to see this fight and i want
to see the best
46 year old anderson silva against
jake paul in other words but to make it
even so
logan paul has no experience right yeah
he's never won a boxing yet he's oh and
two and yeah
yeah so to make competitive once you
just say
do both you do whatever you want so for
logan to make up for
no technique no experience sure can't he
do steroids sure i mean he could
i don't know that he would need it it
wouldn't hurt him
uh here's here's here's what i think i'm
actually saying
branson compete you want him to do trt
i'm worried that
let me be diplomatic i feel like i
wouldn't be surprised if mr silva
at his later age has been already doing
something well he's already tested
positive right
yeah and so i wonder what happens to a
46 year old body
when you are off that stuff he's not
gonna right
what's that he's he's definitely not
gonna be able to he can't be he looks
it's not he's like phenomenal i gotta
see that fight i can't believe i didn't
see i can't believe i didn't even know
about a month ago
i just think you should because if
you're if you're going to say all right
whatever we're going to turn a blind eye
i think both guys should be able to wear
the [ __ ] they want
uh because logan doesn't have the
experience the technique yeah
it's like he's at such a disadvantage
okay i agree so here's my question
i have no problem with that you know why
i'm not so sure steroids would help him
you know i mean i don't know if they're
going to hurt him the difference becomes
unshredded
yeah but do you think it would help him
yes yeah yeah in what sense though you
just like power quickness speed recovery
special recovery i just think if you're
going to say
you this guy can't know you you got to
let both of them do it
cause logan's a huge disadvantage and
then you say now
not only do you not have the experience
but now fight a of anderson silva who
we're going to let do all the steroids
and logan's like what the [ __ ] he's
already like
he's i think the odds have logan you're
kind of favored in that fight already
that's
that's what's insane that's hilarious to
me but but to your point i need to know
if is
like is it eight rounds is it four
rounds and six rounds how serious is it
yeah you know right
i admire logan for taking that fight how
do you not admire him
that's a tough gig it's a scary game
dude that's a tough fight yeah
how about how about woodley or not
woodley uh jake paul
and the talks of connor heating up so
what is he not
especially now like because think about
conor so what fights are left for him
the nate diaz fight was never going away
that's always going to sell
two million pay-per-views yeah outside
that who's the big money fight
i don't want to see him fight jake paul
no jake paul yeah i won't see him fight
no boy again
jake paul take fight but that only
happens if jake beats woodley
like if jake loses that all this stops
you think so all this stuff all that
yeah
it stops all the before he knocks him
out all this
this all goes like all right we saw it
we're done
it all stops a lot of pressure on jake
yeah again i admire that i admire that
he's taking him out just
not easy fighting no i admire these
[ __ ] me too
they have a work ethic they they they do
and they're both good athletes
and they are say what you will they're
so good at [ __ ] getting
jake i mean now you're cooking with fire
if he beats woodley like will he's a
legit [ __ ]
fighter and a little crazy athlete if he
beats woodland i bet you're gonna get
the conor mcgregor fight
jake verscon is there a weight class
that those guys are fighting that are
they fighting at 185
do something weird i thought it was 190
or 180. because i don't think i don't
think woodley has any problem being 185
no he's
he probably walks around at what jake uh
we'll be on 190.
so both kind of that's easy for both of
them to make
yeah if connor and jake fight what do
you think they'd be fighting at because
con is what one
third oh he's one i don't think he
fights i don't think uh i don't i
i think connor doesn't weigh more than
170 right no i agree
but i but for that you know connor's
gonna have to give up something for to
get because jake
it's crazy we're saying this jake's
withdrawal
jake is the truck well he hasn't lost
connor's coming up and connor's won one
fight in five years connor's always
gonna be a draw though
but i'm just saying in this they like if
jake were to start
woodley then it's jake's he'll be like
we're day
and connor's like i don't weigh one day
he's like then i'm not fighting you so
there's
so he's not there's no way jason take
the fight cut down to 170. that's
impossible for him
no i think he just fights in his way
like logan floyd where there's gonna be
like
yeah and and connor will probably have
his hands full yeah
i don't know i don't know dude it's such
a weird world
yeah probably it's a weird world but
again
it all stops august 26th 27th when
jake and woodley fight if woodley man
handles
jake all this goes away all this goes
away there's no like because then
you can't have conor jake fight because
you know jj when is this fight i'm sorry
when is this
august 26th or 27th on showtime
do you have any insight on your boy um
uh deontay wilder
he has yeah he's a whole new camp every
camp focused
focused i would not bet against them you
would not bet against oh
really over tyson how does he solve the
fact that
tyson figured out he couldn't find on
his back foot we'll see but that's what
he's been training for
yeah it's a good fight he's hungry and
he's a real man
career's on the line i would not bet on
that fight really
wow when's that fight not to october it
got pushed because of coving
they're one and one in there right
technically but yeah well most people
thought fury's
won the first one too they think they're
2-0 but yeah they've run it for a third
time yeah the first one
when when the fact that fury got knocked
down toward the end there i
you know it i i had i like i wasn't mad
at the draw
no i like draws yeah is that a chin
that's pretty much it all right let's
get here first let them do steroids come
see me and um
are you on the road this weekend b i'm
on the road this weekend i'm at the
ontario improv
this weekend thursday friday saturday
i'll be here
um you're gonna do you're not staying up
there no no no no
i'll i'll drive the three hours down to
the inland empire
i'll try the hour before if there's a
traffic could be four my friend now i
got i got the tesla i'll put it in self
drive
i got san diego california american
comedy club one
night august 4th i got houston texas
improv august 19
2021. i got buffalo new york helium
september 9th 11th yep and then denver
colorado comedy works
probably my favorite club in the country
almost everyone talks so highly
september 23 24-25
that one's legit like when peop you know
what people tell you like uh cap cities
no no no not [ __ ] comedy works is a real
deal oh
that's what i hear the closest thing you
get to the greatest shows of my
that and what the old improv in fort
lauderdale
some of the best shows of my life
there's improv now in fort lauderdale
yeah they've changed well they
read they redid the whole [ __ ] thing
yeah have you done it yet no i
can't wait it's gonna be sick i love
florida
west palm uh you know all those places
like naples
best i think naples is great tampa's
great temple is great i love tampa i
mean you gotta love all of it man
florida is always uh chappelle and i
with david lucas this thursday friday
saturday it's gonna be coma comedy club
tacoma washington july 29th
31st cal will be there with his mustache
and his weird uh
flavor saver uh north carolina
august 19th through august 21st then la
jolla comedy store la jolla california
is two shows friday august 27th and then
uh one show sunday right now august 29th
we will be out in shows
impressive i know right love it we will
be adding shows there so get your
tickets now those are selling out
already
august 27th through 29th is la jolla in
san jose california september 9th
through september 11th
san jose improv san antonio the big boy
september 24th through the 25th
uh san antonio texas bud light event
center all right that's it kids
chappelle what do you got uh august 26th
brea improv
there's some stuff in october there's a
lot of stuff in october a lot of dates
with you in
yeah august and september i'm doing that
san antonio one
and then uh but yeah october hold on
what does tampa say october
9th through the i know it's october 7th
through the 9th
i'll be in tampa florida at side
splitters in october 28th
through the 20 through the 30th i'll be
in washington dc
oh then later in november tacoma doing a
one-nighter there november 17th and then
a one-nighter in spokane
november 18th boom you jump around a
little bit there
one nighter in spokane i like your style
very fun man all right kids tickets for
all three of us at fhkz.com
new vlog for think boys up right now you
can see my car go through the
transformation that kyle
shot hi kids love you